et jean baptiste lemoyne est notre
invité ce soir en duplex de notre studio
d'auxerre bonsoir vous étiez encore
vendredi dernier à auxerre au meeting de
françois baroin en soutien à françois
fillon
alors pourquoi ce revirement maintenant
la mise en examen est passée par là on
le savait depuis longtemps et ce qui est
un rapport j'étais présent au meeting de
serre par respect pour sa paroisse mais
vous avez observé que n'ai pas pu y
prendre la parole
voilà donc mon discours a été diffusé
sur internet
bon déjà ça donnait un petit peu
l'ambiance un état d'esprit et vous
savez effectivement vous le dites le 14
mars
françois fillon a été mise en examen et
moi j'ai en tête comme les millions de
français qui a acquis il s'est adressé
les yeux dans les yeux
le 27 janvier lors d'un journal télévisé
et qui leur a dit je cite il n'y a
qu'une chose qui m'empêcherait d'être
candidat c'est simon honneur était
atteint si j'étais mis en examen nous y
sommes
et on voit bien que il ya un délitement
de notre vie démocratique qui fait qu'il
ya un besoin de redonner confiance dans
la parole publique d'un parole politique
alors j'en fais ça veut dire que c'est
un choix pour emmanuel macron où c'est
un choix contre françois fillon en gros
c'est l'adhésion ou du rejet non pas du
tout c'est une adhésion pour essayer de
retrouver de l'espérance pour la france
on voit que notre pays n'est pas dans
une situation flamboyante et moi ma
crainte c'est que avec françois fillon
l'alternance soit devenu impossible et
donc j'ai pris connaissance avec
attention du projet pour la france d'
emmanuel macron et j'ai vu énormément
d'éléments en matière régaliennes en
matière économique et sociale qui sont
exactement dans la philosophie de ce que
nous à droite et au centre nous
défendons depuis des années et parfois
même des réformes que nous n'avons pas
fait en notre temps et donc en réalité
l'alternance que propose emmanuel macron
sin alternance n'ont pas d'ailleurs avec
les cinq dernières années mais avec les
30 dernières années où la génération qui
nous a précédés à nous on est tous les
deux je dirais pas très loin des 40 ans
mais la génération qui nous a précédés
et bien tous gouvernements confondus
elle nous a laissé quand même une dette
et un chômage de masse important alors
je crois que on a envie de dire ben
voilà il ya une génération
envie de se retrousser les manches qui a
envie d'aller à l'efficacité peut-être
de mettre de côté certains dogmes
idéologiques et encore une fois aller à
ce qui marche pour recréer de l'emploi
recréer de la cohésion parce que moi
j'ai très inquiet de la situation de la
france qui par rapport à votre démarche
vous proposer d'écouter l'un de vos
collègues le socialiste françois patriat
ça a été l'un des premiers à rejoindre
emmanuel macron si son soutien et sur
des bases claires et qu'il en a lui-même
parlé avec avec l'état-major dans marche
ça me paraît une décision courageux de
sa part il faudra qu'ils les façades et
courage pour qu'elles n'apparaissent pas
comme opportuniste
je ne le fais pas de procès d'intention
j'imagine que s'il le fait il le faire
en pensant que la démarche que nous
avons initié est une démarche nouvelle
qui renverse les tabous qui renverse les
schémas qui qui met à mal les partis de
gouvernement
alors françois patriat a utilisé le mot
opportuniste et vaudraient tracteur eux
aussi n'ont pas tardé à réagir un
jean-baptiste lemoyne ils ont rappelé
comme françois sauvadet votre proximité
passée avec jean françois copé puis vous
avez soutenu alain juppé et puis vous
avez vous êtes maintenant avec emmanuel
macron et puis comme henri de raincourt
le député guillaume larrivé lui parle de
trahison lamentable d'un ralliement
opportuniste alors est ce que vous êtes
une girouette opportuniste jean-baptiste
lemoyne
vous avez remarqué que monsieur patriat
mais comme beaucoup des 5 ou 600
messages de soutien que j'ai reçus par
sms les trois quarts ont ce mot de
courage qui reviennent en oui
aujourd'hui pardon c'était pas simple
mais j'estime que il est temps est bien
de construire quelque chose de nouveau
on le voit bien la confiance elle est
altérée entre les citoyens et le monde
politique
donc moi vous savez je suis constant en
j'ai été élu en candidat indépendant au
sénat indépendant des partis et j'ai
fait campagne avec marc et de mab de ma
main
la moralisation de la vie politique donc
je suis au rendez vous de mes
engagements des engagements pris devant
les grands électeurs de l'yonne et je
crois que sort est l inverse si je
m'étais tu si je n'ai pas tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé que je n'aurais pas
été fidèle et bien au message que
j'avais porté
merci jean baptiste lemoyne d'avoir
accepté notre invitation positive en
duplex de notre studio d'auxerre